tomorrow's inflation numbers are going
to say so we're happy to have this
session on inflation without knowing
what tomorrow's inflation numbers will
say but I'd like to start Governor by
asking the witnesses to introduce
themselves with starting with yourself
yes thank you thank you chair Andrew
Bailey governor of the bank of England
economists at the bank and a member of
the monetary board security
professor of Economics at the LSC and
external member of the monetary policy
committee and Catherine uh Catherine I'm
an external member of the NBC and also a
professor at Brenda University
and Professor tinro I think this is the
last time we have the pleasure of
grilling you so thank you very much for
your time on the monetary policy
committee
uh given that we don't know what
tomorrow's inflation number is going to
say I'm going to focus on what we've
seen since you were last in front of us
to talk about inflation Governor which
was in February and would you say that
inflation today is higher than you were
expecting when you were last in front of
us uh yes it is
um we were expecting a gradual decline
in inflation up to this point and of
course we are below the peak of 11 just
over 11.
but it's about at 0.8 percent higher
than we expected it to be in the
February monetary policy report now we
don't know what as you said wrong we
don't know what's in tomorrow's release
we do know that uh an annual but quite
large a large annual base effect will
come out tomorrow that's the annual
energy
base effect and that's a product of the
off-gem six monthly reset in April last
year but we don't know what the number
is so yes that would have happened by
now uh as I recall from your evidence
that you thought that things would have
turned the corner we'd be in single
digits again by now and you've just said
it's 0.8 percent worse than you were
thinking it would be in February which
is you know given your remit is two
percent that's quite a big margin so I
mean I do I I do stand by The View that
it has turned to the corner and I was
very careful when I you know I said that
a few months ago that we were seeing the
first signs of that because obviously
the peak was 11
and we have seen the benefits already of
some some of the benefits of energy
prices but it is it is higher than we're
expected to be and there are two
underlying reasons for that that we see
in in the data one is food
uh and the second one is
some Goods particularly clothing and
Footwear
um now what should I should just make
the points that it's it's interesting to
note that those are not the elements of
inflation that we regard as the more
persistent elements that's more in the
services sector whereas so far it's
tracking more or less as we thought it
would in in February but we have seen
your right your rights say we have seen
these upsides on these particular two
areas what's gone wrong then either with
your models or with your network of
Agents uh you know it's not something
that any of us would have found
surprising at food prices for example
were persistently strong that our
farmers were telling us about how much
inputs were costing them and things like
that something has gone really well
modeling and with your network of Agents
Edge in terms of information on food let
me let me say it's obviously a question
that we've spent a lot of time on as
well as you can imagine
what I would say is that back in
February
um t23 yes the shares oh yes
um
the contacts that our agents were
talking to this is a point where food
price inflation I think it was around 15
if I remember right that's the food
element
and the contacts were telling our agents
that they thought that was the peak
and that it would come down from there
onwards over the rest of this year
now you're right that has turned out not
to be the peak we've invested a lot of
time and efforts
including me going around the country
talking to the contacts again to say
what what has caused this to happen I
should say that they are they remain of
the view that it is going to come down
um but it's obviously it's gone up in
the meantime now there's two reasons
that
um I would say or two groups of reasons
they give and they say look they were
wrong in this view
um
the first group is things that I think
it's reasonable to say couldn't have
been expected in other words events that
have happened in the meantime
they in certain elements of food and
they're mainly weather events around the
world frankly so there was a well-known
thing with vegetables
um in I think it's Morocco particularly
sugar is a is the one commodity that is
still when it costs the board his price
is still Rising the there are a series
of weather events in other parts of the
world given for that so there's some
things like that there's also a story
about avian flu
those things are things that I think
genuinely you know you can't predict
from sort of you know from period to
period
I think the second thing it is however
the question and it goes to what you
were saying a few moments ago
um and I think two things I get told and
I was on a farm last week actually
um talking to a producer uh who's also a
producer of final output as well
and they said two things one is
energy the impact of energy prices on
businesses is quite
it's quite unevenly distributed it's not
like domestic energy House of energy
prices which have been in a sense set by
government policy it really depends on
when you renew your energy contract I
mean you may pick this up in your
constituencies some businesses you know
have done done much better because the
timing of the reset of their energy
contract worked in their favor
um some have had the absolutely opposite
effect and so it's very uneven
I think the second thing is and this is
perhaps where the prediction issue comes
in I think
what was possibly underestimated is the
degree to which food producers have
purchased
more forward in terms of raw material
suppliers than they would normally do in
other words they've locked in higher
prices for somewhat longer and the
reason they did that is related to
Russia Ukraine actually which is they
were worried about the absolutely
actually getting older so so the farm I
was on last week said they bought
fertilizer further forward than they
would normally do locked in a higher
price than that now I think that should
we I mean I think you're right we you
know question you know it should have
been possible to identify that I think I
mean it's hard it's a bit harder to
quantify but it was in there somewhere
in the mix whereas the weather events
weren't and we'll be coming back to food
later on in the session but if I can
turn to Hugh and ask the same question
do the responsibilities for the
forecasting models fall within your area
Hugh most of them do yes so what's gone
wrong with them well I think I mean I
would Echo a lot of the things that were
already being said
um I mean it is very difficult to
forecast
uh at very high frequencies some of the
developments that we've seen given the
magnitude of the shot to take an example
in the in the governor's letter to us
which we're publishing today
um it's now listed as a fourth shock
this food price a rise
added to the list of other shocks that
we've heard in evidence from you before
and um linked to obviously to what
happened with Russia's evil invasion of
Ukraine and and and yet now it's being
listed as a shock when it's something
that's been known about for
um you know well over a year and so my
question really is why have you been so
wrong in terms of your your forecast of
inflation because a margin of error of
0.8 when your target is only two I mean
you're basically completely uh it it
the the errors are so huge relative to
your target that it just undermines
people's confidence in your ability to
to tackle inflation well perhaps I can
sort of take the two pointers slightly
separately in terms of the aggregate
outlook for inflation I mean I agree
with your point that errors of that
magnitude related to our forecast style
sorry relative to our Target level are
large but I think it as you know the
level of inflation today is very very
high and unacceptably high well above
Target
and I think that's a reflection of the
magnitude of the shocks that we have
faced over the past
at the year 18 months Governor told us a
year ago that the impact on food prices
of the invasion was apocalyptic it made
headlines at the time but that was a
word that that was used and so to feed
to be now surprised by the impact on
inflation is seems to us to be a
surprise
I think I think the point I would make
and this will lead in I think to some of
the discussion will have in a second
around the rationalization of recent
policy decisions I think the point I
would make is is that the magnitude of
these sharks has not only affected
um
directly on inflation
but it's also effective how the
pass-through of these shocks may be
transmitted through the value chain
so the indirect effects of energy price
Rises for example may have been
different and had more magnified effects
and also as is well known the second
round effects which are feeding through
in other costs that are faced by food
producers
so I think what is crucial is our
Baseline forecasting framework is based
or developed from the experience of the
last 30 years of inflation targeting
that's a period where we haven't been
exposed to shocks of the magnitude we've
seen be there the energy price shock or
food price shops or indeed some of the
shocks to International Goods prices we
saw in the aftermath of the pandemic
with the supply disruptions that were
associated with that
and I think there's a sort of difficult
question this is the question we face
and our forecast thing is whether the
models and forecasting Frameworks that
we've developed on the basis of the
experience over the last 30 years
whether they capture
possible changes in Behavior given the
magnitude of these shocks
so I gave a talk a few weeks ago around
how to understand the notion of
persistence which is very key to the way
we view inflation
precisely because given the lags in
monetary policy transmission that are
built into the sort of Technology of the
policy that we have responsibility for
when we change policy today as you know
and this is why forecasts are so key to
our framework we are trying to ensure
that we have the appropriate effect on
inflation development at the time those
lags unwind
um are you saying that despite the bank
of England having been in existence for
over 300 years you only look at the last
30 years when you think about what the
risks are to inflation
will know but I think it is crucial that
the regime we have been in the last 30
years the inflation targeting regime is
a regime that's quite successful on
average and it has had an important
effect on behavior in the economy
so we are relying on looking at whether
that behavior within that regime a
regime I think that's helped to
stabilize longer-term inflation
expectations and provide a kind of
crucial anchor to price developments in
the economy
whether the behavior that we've seen in
that where again we could debate
um
what constitutes large and what
constitutes small but I think over that
30-year experience we have not seen
disturbances to Energy prices food
prices and so forth of the magnitude
that we're experiencing now okay so
given that we've had a 0.8 error versus
a two percent Target just in the last
three months since you were in front of
us what are you doing to improve your
models well I think I mean one of the
things we are looking at and this is
discussed at some length in the monetary
policy report for Foods now we're
focusing on food or more generally
sorry
well point eight percent
across so I don't want to preemption
speak about compared to a two percent
Target so I I think I mean at the heart
of what we're trying to do is understand
whether the magnitude of the shock that
we faced and in particular the fact that
we've moved a long way from our Target
because of the magnitude of that shock
whether that is having an impact on
Behavior which means that the way in
which pass-through takes place and which
inflation reverts back to Target has
changed in in some way so the behavior
underlying how different parts of the
economy along the value chain
um how they pass through the incidence
of this shock and ultimately into the
consumer prices that we Target in Agri
are you changing your models as a result
of that new information I mean we're
trying to incorporate new information I
mean what I would emphasize is is that
you know the typical way one would
estimate a forecasting model is to take
a period of experience where you have
the data so we are focused with the
reason I just described on looking at
the data of the last 30 years
and it's almost inevitable if you add a
couple of extra quarters or even an
extra year to 30 years of data you're
not going to fundamentally change the
model
just because the weight of the model
will still be based on that 30-year
experience so what we're facing is we
have
we look at we see these models have led
to some of the errors you're describing
I think we recognize that our forecasts
of inflation have been too low and we're
trying to understand why we have made
those errors interpret those errors
um in terms of the behavior and then
make an assessment as to whether that
behavior will continue into the future
or not and what I think is sort of
crucial to see is is that I mean
obviously models are essentially taking
averages of behavior in the past we
really only have one observation of how
the UK economy responds to having
inflation in the inflation targeting
framework at the 10 level so you're
saying the inflationary period in the
1970s because it falls outside your
period is not really one that you want
to use in your models well we think I
mean
so just let me continue because I think
you make a good point is that the
question then becomes given that we have
inflation at 10 and we've had the
magnitude of shock that we haven't seen
in that 30-year period has Behavior
changed and of course one way you could
look at that is look in detail at
developments that are going on right now
and I think the governor described how
we look in detail at food prices but
we're looking in detail at lots of other
parts of the economy but there are other
ways to think about that and I think you
know you've gave an illustration we do
think about should we be using models or
revisiting Frameworks that were applied
in the 19 to the data of the 1970s and
80s but crucially while there may be
something to learn from that I think
there's also reasons to think that that
experience is not immediately relevant
to here which goes back to my point that
that's an experience in the 1970s and
80s where there was not an inflation
Target and therefore this anchor for
Price developments provided by the
inflation Target and an independent NPC
seeking to get back to to get inflation
developments back to the inflation
Target was absent and I think we do see
in the 70s in particular in the 70s 90s
in that period evidence that longer-term
inflation expectations became somewhat
de-anchored I think the evidence of that
in this experience is different and
importantly so because it's that anchor
and the fact that longer-term inflation
expectations haven't drifted away from
Target that's providing a sort of core
element of what are forecasting so yes
we can learn from some of the experience
of the past but the world is very
different from the past in many respects
the structure of the UK labor market is
very different the structure of the
economy more widely is different and in
particular the regime in which monetary
policy is conducted is very different do
you know do you know what really worries
me and what um slightly making me
despair actually hearing you talk about
this looking back over the last 30 years
primarily because that's when you had
the bank of England's inflation Target
that had become anchored I remember
bankers and Traders telling me exactly
the same thing in
2007-2008 that this has been different
the last 10 years look how low
volatility is and there was I who'd gone
through all the shocks of the 90s saying
No this could get much much worse and I
feel that you may have made the same
sort of error as bankers and Traders did
running into the financial crash well
can I just say one thing about that
because I mean I think and we will talk
about this I think in a moment but we
are producing a baseline forecast and I
think the Baseline forecast the modal
forecast and the language that was used
in the most recent monetary policy
report
I think that is essentially using the
experience of the last 30 years we we
have introduced some additional judgment
collectively as a committee in order to
induce greater persistence in inflation
than the experience of the last 30 years
would suggest but that's a relatively
modest increase but what we've also done
and I think reflecting precisely the
concerns that you are describing is
we've introduced what we call a skew or
some a skew to the risks around that
Baseline forecast and I think that skew
is not really justified by the modeling
of the last 30 years that possibility
that inflation may be much higher but
that possibility that inflation could be
higher or more persistently above the
Target and take longer to get back down
to the Target I think that is motivated
by right variety of factors looking at
the forecast errors looking at behavior
that we can see in the economy right now
but also by the type of experience the
type of need to entertain the type of
policy possible abilities that you're
describing so I think it's it's one
thing to say that we're concerned about
that risk and I think without wanting to
sort of front run some of the questions
that you have on your script coming out
I think at least for me and I think
probably in terms of the median person
on the committee and the resulting votes
of the committee as a whole that risk
that skew in the outlook for inflation
towards the upside
the greater likelihood that inflation
will run above the modal Baseline view
based on the experience of the last 30
years certainly than below it it's that
skew that is
um rationalizing and justifying the
increase in interest rates we made for
example at our last meeting so it there
is an attempt
um and I think it's important to
emphasize it's an attempt that has to be
based to some extent on judgment
but a judgment that is entertaining the
risks that that you have just described
I'm sure we'll
actually going to bring in my colleague
who's going to talk about bank rate but
um uh we will we will no doubt have an
opportunity to hear at the point in a
moment uh John thanks Joe good morning
everyone
um in looking at bank rate going forward
can I just ask
um I think some of us are very fair to
say have long been long believed that
central banks and including the bank of
England have been well behind the curve
with regards inflation
but you know forecasting has been a rise
the chair has said
um we've been you know Bank of England
is one amongst others that have been too
slow in raising interest rates allowing
in you know inflation to mushroom well
above the two percent Target
um and and I've put this strongly
suggesting it's been a woeful neglect of
Duty and it's causing real pain out
there
with people and businesses
um and I think we should always remember
as we sit in our
sometimes white Ivory Towers having
these debates that we're talking about
people's lives and businesses that are
having to Grapple with double-digit
inflation and interest rates perhaps
going up too fast and I think you get it
but I think it's useful to remind
ourselves of that I mean I suppose my
question to you is why should the public
have confidence in your ability to get
it right going forward
and what lessons do you think you've
learned what are you going to do
differently because I'm not hearing a
satisfactory answer to that and perhaps
I could start with you Andrew
I think there are and I think he was
already referred to these I think there
are very big lessons about how we deal
with how we operate monetary policy in
the face of very big shocks
there's the shocks that we've faced have
been unprecedented and I mean not just
in the last 30 years actually
um and I think we will you know I think
there are big lessons about how do we
operate policy in that world and in a
world of very substantial uncertainty
because I I know I do have to say this
quite often in these hearings that you
know we have to make policy in real time
we don't make policy with the benefit
defined sites
um you know we've had to respond to
shocks as they've occurred I think there
is a genuine debate about the with with
food for instance not so much about the
shock itself which as you said I mean
you know I think at this exactly this
hearing a year ago I referred to my
concern about food prices and what would
happen to them following the invasion
but actually about the longevity of the
pass-through of food prices and how we
you know what we learn about that so I
think we have a lot to learn
about operating monetary policy in a
world a big shop we can't just yeah we
want to what I do want to say and I
think he's described it very well is
first of all we share the concern we
share the concern of the constituents
there is there is no no good comes of
this and we've got to get on top of it
and we've got to bring inflation back
down to Target and as he said yeah the
reason we have raised interest rates
further and the reason that we are not
following the model so to speak if we
can sort of generalize for a moment
about that is because we are concerned
that there are these what we tend to
call asymmetric effects as we bring in
inflation down from very high levels and
we have to direct policy at that and
that is why we've taken a conscious
decision to yeah to aim off that that if
you like that sort of mobile case that
the model is giving us because we think
it is too it's too symmetric that the
inflation goes up inflation comes down
and we think there are there are risks
of persistence and we have to respond to
those and I think what I would very much
say to it yeah to everybody who
obviously you know does watch with a
critical eye what we do and I understand
that completely in the world we're in is
that is what we're doing you know we are
focused very much on what we need to do
to guard against what we see as these
risks
I I hear the bank talk a lot about
supply side shops and yeah the biggest
one and that's the fair point the
biggest one of course was Russia's
invasion of the UK
um but you know by their very nature you
cannot predict Black Swan events and um
I think so Dave ramsden um yes
misunderstood misrepresented my position
towards the end of our session on
Thursday at the bank of England when he
said you know you expect us to to
predict black small a bit we all know
they can't people no by definition they
can't be predicted they just can't be
predicted one's not saying that what one
can say is
is that forecasting needs to be improved
I mean the biggest black small event was
Ukraine now if I put it to you that um
the latest or the last inflation figures
we had the bomb prior to the invasion
inflation is running at 6.2 percent the
bank rate was still half a percent I
mean isn't the truth of the matter is
that you were well behind the curve then
before the biggest shock came along
I mean you know I
it's a difficult one to get away from
isn't it because
can I go back over the what I call the
sequence of shocks that we've had and
and and put it into the context of the
judgments we had to make in real time
because it's important so the first
shock
was what we tend to call the supply
chain shot coming out of covert
um that's a global shock
uh a lot of it had to do with not just
disrupted Supply chains but also the
switch from demand for services to
demand for goods which are more traded
that was a shock and I you know I hold
my hand up you can read you know I made
a speech in September 2021 on this
subject actually
when that was the dominant shock
um and you're right inflation was rising
at that point
but we
we did take the view at that point that
in a world where that was the shock that
we were facing that there were grounds
for thinking that that shock would would
be transient
important point in that speech I also
highlighted my concerns about the labor
market in this country I'll come back to
that in a moment
actually we can now look back and say if
the only shop that had a curb would be
the one that we were looking at at that
point in time the global supply chain
shock it largely did turn out to be
Transcendent unfortunately it was then
swamped by
as you said the big shock that came
along which was Russia Ukraine
now I just want to come back to the UK
labor market because that's the
important one we've discussed it many
times in that speech I made in September
2021 I did say I was concerned about the
UK labor market and that was a source of
of a potential inflationary pressure
going forwards
now the the challenge we had at that
point so I've been at this ground a few
times before but I just want to say
briefly was
we the first game came to an end at the
end of that month September 2021
um around about I think a million jobs
were furlade until right the last day of
that scheme
and we and every frankly I think every
other forecaster I can remember in the
outside
was having the task of saying what is
going to be the effect on the labor
market of that coming to an end and I
think all forecasters felt that it was
going to cause scarring it was going to
cause an increase in unemployment it
would loosen the labor markets uh and
that would have an effect on
inflationary pressures now it did they
didn't
we now know it didn't
and I think you know yeah
yes we hold our hand up and say that's a
judgment we had to make and it didn't
turn out right but I I just want to put
it back into the context of the time
because you know that was a very
difficult and unusual time a period of
time we made a judgment I I would also
say I think pretty much every other
forecaster made the same judgment okay
and it didn't turn out to be the correct
one all right I mean I'm I take it that
these are never easy decisions but my
interest and I do mean that is the
seldom black and white in the world
there's always lots of nuances but I'm
not interested in other forecasters I'm
interested in the Bank of England that
is our responsibility to the British
public here I mean we talk about history
um you go back into history and to my
knowledge and I will be happy to be
stand corrected there has never been a
period where inflation has hit double
digits
and then come back to levels of two two
and a half percent which not so long ago
a lot of our forecasters are forecasting
only a few months ago in fact
um within two years it has not dropped
that far within two years why did the
bank of England think it was going to be
different this time
well we've I mean this goes back to what
he was saying I think we have built more
persistence into our forecast so the
model would tell you it would come down
much more quickly than that actually and
and we rather like you actually really
don't believe that we think it's just
too symmetric
so we've built more persistence into the
into the profile of inflation but there
are
I mean there are big effects going to
work through this year through Energy
prices but but if I may suggest Andrew
history suggests that Hugh mentioned 30
years you go back to Overlook at
inflation over 100 years it has never
gone into double digits and returned to
two and a half three percent
within two years if you don't mind
saying you also made the important point
that throughout much of art history we
did not have a regime in which monetary
policy was operated to bring it back to
Target
now that's what we're doing
that's what we will do we've said we'll
be it is evidence driven so if we see
more evidence of persistence we've been
very clear in what we're saying we will
have to respond to it well you've
already in the way May the 11th you
increased your end of year inflation
forecast correctly if I run from 3.9 to
5.4 percent yes that is a hell of a jump
from any Central Bank when it comes to
forecasting so you're already accepting
that inflation is going to be more
persistent yes
do the ladies I think I've had a note
suggesting that ladies want to catch my
eyes I've been naughty I've been hogging
you Andrew sorry that's okay
but just coming back to your question I
discussed discussing many of my
Sports in front of this committee What
alternative policy decisions would have
looked like
and in thinking about this it helps to
focus on the fact that monetary policy
can reduce inflation by reducing demand
increasing unemployment and reducing
nominal and real wages so that's how
monetary policy transmits so rather than
focusing on interest rates another way
of asking the question you just asked is
could the NPC have generated a bigger
slowing down in demand than the one we
have seen we higher unemployment which
would have led to a lower inflation
right now and so I've shown in several
different simulations what that might
have looked like if we had somehow known
about the energy shock or the sequence
of energy shocks uh in well in advance
including Ukraine yeah
you misrepresented
inadvertently I'm not suggesting you
should have known about the innovation
so suppose we had known so even you know
before uh and so uh I I asked okay you
know how about Us increasing interest
rates by five percentage points more
than we did starting that increase uh
back in uh July 2021. so very early on
2021 uh in July inflation was exactly
two percent but we were expecting it an
increase coming so increasing rates to
around eight percent
um uh starting back then
slowly okay unemployment would have been
about three percentage points higher
which uh you know there are issues about
how to get that unemployment with a
fellow scheme but let's leave that aside
uh then the benefit for inflation right
now would have been relatively small I
mean reducing the peak to nine percent
uh which would have been sealed well
above time okay okay crucially for our
agreement let me just finish this point
crucially for our remit uh we focus on
achieving the Target in the medium term
the simulation shows that if you apply
the title policy that would have led to
a massive undershooting of the Target in
the medium term which would not have
been consistent with our remit and this
has to do with the shape of the shock
it's an increase in price level and the
tool that we have that only operates
after you know a single okay I think
I'll be returning to that later I think
you need to let other colleagues in yeah
thank you John Amory
assistance
um I think we will recognize that it's a
big risk I think I will probably work
with words in your mouth so it is
persistent right now and it seems to me
that maybe we've got to a point where a
simple formula where put the rates up
inflation will come down is frankly not
fit for purpose
clearly in all the work that you have
done you have begun to tweak that I hear
all you say about shock events and the
impact but that is very much focused on
the supplier producer side not consumer
Behavior size and I think it was you
Hugh who actually made the point earlier
but this is what's really different
and I think therefore my question to you
is what have you done to dig down in to
really understanding what that
behavioral change is are people just
thinking differently because of the
impact of of covet is there a sense that
the government will pick this up out of
covid they'll pick us up out of anything
so we just keep spending because it'll
just be fine what is that behavioral
change and have we got to a point where
that straight intervention by the bank
effectively through interest rates to
get inflation down
can't any longer work in a vacuum and
you need other things into the mix from
government or other agencies to actually
bring inflation down
so I think um can I just a little bit in
the spirit to sort of pick up of a talk
I gave quite recently which I think
addresses this point so I agree with you
persistence is sort of the key question
in the current environment and there is
a sense in which it's always the key
question from a monetary policy point of
view given the lacks in monetary policy
transmission which have been discussed
it's it's always that we have to look
forward and we have to think about what
inflation will still be there at that 18
month to two year Horizon when what we
do with monetary policy today actually
has its maximal effect on price
developments so persistence is key but
not all persistence is the same I mean
I'm a bit repeating back your questions
you hear using my language so one form
of persistence which I've called
extrinsic persistence is just that you
get a series of shocks to use Andrew
Andrew's language which push inflation
up and we've seen the consequences of
the pandemic in terms of Supply
disruption in Supply chains at the
global level we've seen the impact of
higher energy prices
um tightness of the labor market in the
UK associated with maybe
pandemic-induced restrictions to labor
Supply these are all things I think
we're going to come back to and of
course food prices too as we were
discussing earlier
um and each of those shocks comes
through on the supply side it pushes
prices up it creates a difficult
trade-off for monetary policy because
prices are going up at a time when the
impact on the real spending power of UK
residences being squeezed and this
creates exactly the Dilemma
and the difficulty for households and
businesses we were just discussing so I
think our job is to manage that so that
one interpretation is you've had this
sequence of events one after the other
that have all gone in the same direction
and have produced persistence in
aggregate inflation but for a series of
uh of inflationary shocks one after the
other so just as you think you're
getting through one another one comes
but I think the challenge to that view
and that's a view that probably would
you would say yes we can measure that
using our models using our experience in
the last 30 years we can't predict
shocks otherwise they wouldn't be shocks
so we just have to you know add up those
things
I think the key question is first are
there what I would call multiplicative
effects across these shocks so they
interact with one another in ways that
aren't captured by just adding up and I
think Andrew was getting to this point
about the tightness of the labor market
associated with these um disruptions to
labor Supply early retirement long-term
sickness and so forth these the
tightness of the labor market interacted
with the cost higher cost of energy the
higher cost of imported goods in ways
that created greater persistence in
aggregate inflation than we would have
expected on previous experience and then
on top of that and I'd probably get into
your point on top of that I think there
is the question of whether
behavior is just different and it's it
may be consumer Behavior but it may also
be the behavior of firms and how they
price it may be the behavior of banks in
how they lend so lots of parts of how
the inflation process works in the
economy and how monetary policy actions
feed through to the inflation process
along the transmission mechanism these
may have been changed because the way
people behave when inflation's at 10
could just be different from the way
people behave when inflation is at or
close to two percent and I challenge you
and say I don't think the change in
behavior is just about the percentage
points it's about the cultural norms
which have changed fundamentally in
society following particularly covet
so I mean that is a a conjecture I mean
I think you know we have talked a lot
which is is a similar story but a
different story a distinct sort of think
around whether we have a shifted into a
world of slightly more inflationary
psychology and that becomes a little bit
self-fulfilling now that's not to say
that we've de-anchored longer-term
inflation expectations but precisely
because it seems like inflation is more
persistence people behave in a way which
actually generates greater persistence
now to to your consequence what is it
that can be done to address this because
it seems to me that the power to change
this is not in the hand only at the bank
of England that has to be with your
effort between the bank of England and
government policy and it's that peace a
really very interesting point
so I remember I mean in quite a few
hearings over the sort of since covert
began I know we've been asked questions
about scarring particularly early on
and I think we all I think we tended to
interpret those questions in a rather
sort of
convention traditional sort of sense of
scarring in terms of damage to capacity
in the economy often through the sort of
failure of firms for instance we've
learned quite a lot of questions on
scarring not just in his committee I
mean but generally the concern was how
many how many firms are going to fail as
a result of the impact of covert and
what's it going to do to the you know to
the productive capacity of the economy
I mean I think your questions were
interesting because I look back on it
today I'll look at it today I'm back on
it I think I'm not sure that's the right
that was the I mean it turned out not to
be the right way to look at it I think
the interesting point is and I think I'd
take this to be the sort of Point you're
going to which is what impact has it had
on the labor market and people's in a
sense
supply of labor into the market
uh and we do see changes I mean the
whole question of participation in the
labor force has changed
um it's beginning to head backwards but
actually
that head backwards is very concentrated
amongst the younger age workers not not
this somewhat older group
so I think we do see changes in terms of
the labor Supply which we didn't predict
I think it's true to say these changes
that have come out of covert now part of
it of course it is a medical story
unfortunately but I think there's a bit
more to it I mean the evidence of this
is rather more to it than that probably
so I do think this is you know you ask a
really interesting question I do think
we're learning things from covert as we
go along in terms of the Legacy it's
having
I was the head of macroeconomic
forecasting for the oecd and for
Citibank so I know a lot about models
and what what they can do what they
can't do skeletons in the closet and so
forth
um I started talking about persistence
in January 2021.
I wrote about my concerns about
underlying strength in the economy uh
and the prospects for persistence in
price setting and wage setting in my
annual report to you folks last August
the committee started talking about
persistence in November 2021 so
persistence has been on our radar for a
very long time
um now you know that I have tended to
vote uh not with the majority I have
tended to vote for higher uh bank rate
changes at most of the meetings last
year that's because in my view we were
underestimating the degree of
persistence the Persistence of
persistence in our judgment the model
was never telling us about persistence
primarily because it was estimated
non-historical data it is linear and
therefore cannot address some of these
behavioral changes that we observe at
the micro level we do get information
from our DMP from our agents from our n
nmg from our various high frequency and
very granular information but we may
collectively or individually we make
different judgments about how to
incorporate that data into or based you
know the model forecast and then
incorporate additional information that
we are getting from our higher frequency
data that is the judgments that
individually we bring to the committee
uh so you know there we can we can we
end up with a best Collective judgment
uh and I think this time around in our
presentation of the modal forecast and
the mean forecast where the mean
forecast incorporates a substantially
higher degree of persistence coming from
both more resilient household spending
as well as a dynamic between producer
between firms as they price in the
marketplace and consumers as they choose
or not to buy
some things everybody has to buy clarify
for the record I do apologize for
interrupting um but you said DMP and I
think a decision maker panel decision
maker panel yes that's our thing firm
analysis firm level it's monthly so we
get we get quite a bit of information
from that about
the what firms think what they're
pricing now
but also what they think they can get in
the marketplace when they price a year
ahead that's a very important
information because
if they look at households and
households are saying well I think
inflation is going to be four or five
percent next year because again we have
surveys of the households if the
households think of inflation will be
four or five percent next year then
firms say sure I can price at four or
five percent next year so it becomes a
reinforcing Dynamic until consumers
boycott until consumers say I can't
because of a purchasing power cost of
living or I won't pay that high price
ultimately it's consumers who discipline
firms you'll absolutely right Catherine
and that
contribution was really really helpful
but I think what it says to me is that
there is a big piece that we still don't
fully understand and I don't see in the
potential being given to and that is the
dynamic of behavior
put that into if you like the the
modeling we recognize it's an issue but
I don't think we found a solution I'm
not sure I've yet seen the hunger to
find a way of doing that because without
doing that I'm not sure how we're going
to deal with this persistence issue can
I just finish off what I was going to
say just I just want to say as soon as I
want to finish off with when I was
responding because I think you make a
very good point I mean I come back to
sports about Labor participation I think
the question of the incentives to
participate in the labor force is not
something from monetary policy it's
something I think obviously I don't
comment on fiscal policy but it is
naturally in the territory of the school
policy okay
thank you
really interesting can I ask you have
you done any work on whether economic
forecasting is dead and obviously it's
an incredibly valuable tool but you've
heard the Committees unhappiness with it
we've seen how inaccurate it's been was
it a sort of a sick in sixth sense that
told you that this was going to be more
persistent or or do you do scenario
testing would scenario testing be a
better way for members of the public to
see well on the one hand it could look
like this on the other hand if this
proves through it could look like that
do you do some formalized work on
looking at ways to predict the future
that could be better than an economic
forecasting tool that as you say is
linear
so everybody's got a linear model yes so
that's it because it's very difficult to
do non-linearities and asymmetries
within the context of a standard set of
economic models that would just so
that's why bringing judgment uh into a
forecasting exercise is a requirement
and everybody does do it so um
so so
um what you've you heard from
um uh sylvana her scenarios and if you
look at some of my speeches you'll see
my scenarios so in the context of our
communication uh with the with the
public with you and the public or
anybody else who reads the speeches we
provide you with the kind of information
that represents scenarios the question
of whether or not those should be
formalized within the context of the say
monetary policy report
there was scenario testing back in the
con in the covid in covid we also do
different assumptions on our some of our
key assumptions for example constant
rate assumption versus the market yield
curve assumption so there are Avenues to
do scenario testing
so can I then further to that does it
work then having a monetary policy
committee where your speeches Professor
tin raro's speeches are heard but your
your your views and her views are not
acted upon clearly the consensus view
was something different and we are where
we are but is there is does the MPC work
as it's intended to do or is it ending
up with the wrong results in in your
opinion and then I'll ask professor
tenrero and then I'll let the governor
have his titles
um so the uh advantage of the structure
of the MPC is that we both have
individual accountability
as well as a collective judgment
so in the context of individual
accountability we can then re or we know
everybody knows how we vote I mean
that's not true of other central banks
so you know how I vote and you can read
speeches that basically tell you why
okay and that's that is something that
provides quite a bit of information
to the readers of the speeches yeah um
there are other central banks the
Federal Reserve for example where I work
for quite a while uh that has speeches
and a Dot Plot but you don't exactly
know how anybody voted so the pattern of
individual accountability and
communication I think is of its strength
of the the MPC and it is also valuable
as a way of of communicating with the
public the challenges that we face so
you would stick with it as it is there's
also a collect there ultimately has to
be a collective Justice yeah there's
only one bank rate and and have to go a
certain amount sure
um and when I came here to the committee
for my testimony one of the questions
was the balance between individual
accountability and the vote
and the collective judgment
thank you Professor tinero would you
agree with that is the NPC right as it
is would you change it so let me answer
the question you started with which is
can we do without forecast yes the
answer is absolutely not because the
impact of monetary policy is felt in two
years from now or 18 months from now so
we absolutely need to think seriously
about what where inflation is heading in
that Horizon to say my question wasn't
should we do away with it it was should
we move to more scenario testing so as
different Alternatives
analysis and then obviously the question
I'm going back to um Mr Barons uh was
you know what would have happened if you
did things differently and there's where
I think we need to move the conversation
from just a qualitative
assessment yeah you could have moved a
month or six months or you know whatever
earlier versus okay what would have done
to the outcomes of inflation and and the
economy so and these are important
discussions to have and I'm sure we'll
see a lot more work you know going back
and assessing okay what could have been
differently and
um
now let me just reiterate that there was
no escaping a big peak in inflation uh
Just Energy alone at Peak was
contributing four percentage points uh
to inflation and if you add to that food
price inflation which again is a big
tradable component food and another
tradable Goods then you are facing
external inflation of eight percentage
points at a peak of 11 okay this is a
peak so as I said before in this
Committee in order to offset that we
would have needed an enormous deflation
negative inflation which would have
required you know bringing unemployment
to double digits so there's no escaping
given the size the normal size of these
shocks to um to uh have a large peaking
inflation which then triggers the second
round effects most of which are also
unavoided of all in you know obviously
we will they will win but there are many
mechanisms in the economy of implicit or
explicit indexation that means that many
of those second rounds are well embedded
and and that's where monetary policy you
know can lean against over time but um
so so I I just wanted to clarify those
points I'm happy with the NPC the way it
is too oh the FBC is phenomenal in
incense in the sense of bringing
different views and different
perspectives and we have a very healthy
and rigorous discussion of you know
where risks lie and and I think is the
as Catherine said uh the system of
majority voting which is very different
from other central banks is is a very um
thank you um Governor is the NPC fit for
purpose but secondly is there a second
order which is Banks failing to pass on
higher savings rates leading to an
inflationary impact because there is a
disincentive to people to save so
well let me start with NPC thank you I
yeah I welcome the comments the comfort
and sylvana made I am fiercely committed
to the fact that there is no group think
on the NPC and there's transparency that
we deliberate deliberation is at the
heart of what the MPC does and that
different views are expressed and you
know I I haven't had a we haven't had a
unanimous vote for quite a long while
that's that's not a problem to me
uh I'm fiercely committed to this
now I think let me say two things about
the forecasting process which I think
are important one is I think it hasn't
been said yet these are always
conditional forecasts they're
conditioned on a range of market prices
and are conditioned on government policy
particularly on fiscal policy so all our
forecasts are conditional
and things do change so let me give you
an example
we completed our May forecast line about
three weeks ago I guess the gas prices
already 10 lower
than it was three weeks ago
so our forecast today would not be
exactly what it was three weeks ago
so therefore since you are all one way
or another
um Central bankers and economists should
you not get some farmers and some X
money market Traders into the monetary
policy committee because essentially
what you're all saying is that things
move much faster and further than our
models though we condition the forecast
not on what we think the gas price is
going to be but on what the market
thinks the gas price is going to be so
in fact we are embodying the views of
exactly those people
um
okay now they change their view I mean
that's fine I mean that the world
changes they've changed their view in
the last three weeks and it's happening
a lot to us at the moment so we have to
deal with that now the second point I
want to make before I go on to um saving
rates is the forecast is the best
Collective Judgment of the committee now
there is a tension because there's
obviously attention between what I said
about you know Fierce commitment to the
fact that we are not doing group think
here and the fact that we have to come
together and and agree a best Collective
judgment now the way we do that and
particularly at the moment is that it's
a fan chart with risks in it and as Hugh
was saying yeah we've got the biggest
ever upside risk on inflation at the
moment now I know that not all of my
colleagues sitting next to me today will
take the same view on that
that's okay that's okay now we do have
the challenge I will be honest with you
and I think some of this discussion has
Illustrated that in how we communicate
the fact that it's conditional the fact
that it's you know it is a best
Collective Judgment of views it has a
range of views in it that is a challenge
because if I'm honest with you and I can
understand this there is a natural
tendency to want to boil it just tell me
what the number is yeah um as if it's an
unconditional view because I'm running
out of time so that's interesting can I
just ask one final question on that are
persistent public sector strikes causing
problems with the consensus view amongst
the public of where inflation will be
and then can you come on to the savings
rates
well
the the there is always a question which
is really a question of the ons wrestle
with but we have to as well as what is
this what are the effects of the strikes
going to be on on GDP and outputs
um and uh you know they are creating I
mean they are I'm sure creating some
noise in it
um yeah we'll see we tend to look
through that and try to sort of sense
look at underlying output
um in terms of uh inflation
you know obviously we look at the labor
market as a whole because we have to
because there's competition across the
whole labor market uh what I would say
go back to points I was making out about
persistence actually uh and here I'm
talking about particularly private
states of wages uh they're not growing
faster than we thought they would and
actually over time there's evidence that
they are you know gradually coming so
are you saying that the strikes are not
adding to inflation in your view to the
position I don't think we have any sense
of that at the moment no but we do watch
very carefully because they obviously do
and they do introduce some volatility
into uh so
um saving rates you you asked about
survey rates and inflation
so the pass-through of saving rates of
our interest rate saving rates has been
quite different across different parts
of the market so the pass through to
site deposits has been you know been
weaker obviously it's been less than we
have increased rates by I think since we
started increasing rates I see numbers
like about 140 150 basis points so 1.4
1.5 percent whereas obviously we've put
rates up by 4.4 percent now the pass
through to fixed to term deposits has
been okay much stronger but what's the
impact of that in terms of could that in
itself be inflationary in terms of
consumer behavior
um it is something that we do our staff
are doing a lot of work and we're
spending a lot of time on the
transmission mechanism of larger policy
I would say that the bigger elements in
the transmission mechanism is the
mortgage is mortgage rates
um saving rates lower because the
savings are concentrated particularly
amongst those that part of the
population it tends to have a low margin
of propensity to can see them so the
rates don't make that as much effect as
it's mortgages that are more than more
the issue of that okay so you think it's
not having an impact I don't think
that's a big factor okay okay thank you
thanks Andrea Angela well thank you very
much I mean I'm not one of those that
thinks that you should blame the
messenger if the forecasts
um go a bit awry when everyone else's
forecasts have gone at Ryan we're in
great state of volatility so
um I don't particularly have an issue
um I think that economic forecasting is
at least as much art as it is science
and so the more transparent your
thoughts are the better it is for people
to understand how the policy makers are
making decisions which affect them
um so I don't have too much of a worry
about all of that and I don't think it's
ever a good idea to blame or shoot the
messenger I want to talk about
um greed inflation as it's been called
um because there seems to have been a
breakdown now between the relationship
between food producer prices and
consumer food prices
so instead of that Gap get staying the
same it's actually widened and inflation
has gone up which kind of indicates that
there are there might be some
profiteering going on have you seen any
examples or are you worried about
profiteering
I'll I'll cover it from two angles
um
in
food certainly what you're right about
purchaser prices and producer prices are
a leading sort of indicator of consumer
prices I mean that's how it should work
obviously because it's a chain
so I think it comes back to what we're
just discussing earlier which is this
question about why is why is the
pass-through taking longer because at
the commodity price level which is the
sort of start of this chain please
surprise it a bit in the middle
many food prices about nearly all sugars
part of the exception they'd want to
repeats actually last summer in terms of
inflation rates
um so wheat would be a good case and
point where
and that's what led people to think that
the the peak in food prices seep the
Consumer Price inflation would come soon
as it actually has
now I said earlier I think I think there
are you know stories that we hear about
people buying buying forward at higher
prices for longer stories about energy
costs certainly get made we do our
agents do pick up I should say a story
about margins
um this is actually particularly from
producers okay rebuilding margins rather
than yeah
between the one and the other is but
you've taken the words out of my mouth
um it's a story about rebuilding margins
that were squeezed particularly last
year in the early part of it now
um
we'll see
let me switch the other part at the
aggregate level if we look at the
economy as a whole
um we don't have as up-to-date data but
we you know we have looked at
particularly you can interrogate the
sort of the GDP deflator which is the
inflation measure and the GDP statistics
and try to allocate it between wages and
profits this is I have so an extremely
hazardous and sort of difficult thing to
do
at the sort of top level for the UK it
doesn't show a particular story but the
but I have to tell you there are all
sorts of assumptions built into that
which if you'd like I'd be happy to
write
um but please don't expect it to be an
exciting letter
um all your letters are exciting this
one this one will be the one that broke
the mold then in that case
um but what I would say is that I think
when you look at profits The Profit
series I mean interestingly in the UK we
still divide Prof corporate profits into
What's called the north the North Sea
and the non-north Sea which is a
slightly historic thing but it's really
energy versus the rest and as we all
know and energy profits have been higher
and the rest don't show the same Trend
but if you'd like I can I'm certainly
happy to write and set out but food
inflation is up to 45 year high yes and
obviously when prices
um when inflation has been persistent
and as high as it is consumers don't get
to see or notice the way that prices are
moving in quite the same way as if
you're in a more stable situation which
creates a circumstance where could I put
it this way where margins being rebuilt
might sort of stray into profiteering
what is the bank doing about watching
out for that because let's face it I
mean the producers the suppliers and the
consumers are the only people that can
pay for increased food and it looks like
it's all been well I mean the consumers
to me I understand this and I think this
is the appropriate place I think the
competition markets Authority are
looking at this and I think that's the
appropriate place I think they've said
that it's on their radar I mean we pick
up information particularly by our
agents and we you know we're quite
transparent about the information we
pick up and certainly we've heard the
rebuilding story
um and we will watch it very carefully
because
um you know as it evolves and as we get
more information we will certainly let
you know and we'll publish what what
we're getting
um I think that's that you know that's
that's the best thing so let me let me
add one of the you you made the point
that when when prices are very volatile
it's very you know there's wide-ranging
it's both hard to shop because to find a
cheaper thing but also you just don't
even know how much prices are changing
and so it's hard for your consumer
boycott it's hard to talk about earlier
okay so two points two points on that
one is the some included in this
information that we get from the
decision maker panel survey is the
entire distribution of prices so we can
see how wide that distribution is
um The Wider the distribution the more
challenging it is for the consumer to
discipline those prices what we have
seen over the last few months is though
that that has tightened in other words
that creates a stronger main signal for
consumers to latch onto the second point
that I would like to bring in on this
though is I was recently in way sales on
an agent meeting working and and enjoyed
the um the new product development team
at a at a kitchen so I got to eat their
new food it was great I love those kinds
of visits
um um but the point that they were
making is they they create dishes for
restaurants it's a it's a frozen food
but it goes to a restaurant and what
they had found indeed was the challenge
that the restaurants were having in
passing through price increases yeah so
the consumers were disciplining the
pricing uh down to this producer
restaurant level
but you know it's an example it's an
example professor
one observation there's a global
component to all this if you look at
cumulative price inflation uh since uh
December 2019 just before the pandemic
um the inflation food inflation in in
this country has been 25 percent in the
U.S it's been 24 in the Euro area 27 so
we're talking about you know all in
within the same ballpark so there's
there's a big Global component and we
have to think about when we think about
the courses or the drivers um we need to
keep that in mind in government funded
you see profit margins and increasing
markups as a source of persistent
inflation like
you've been warning that wage Rises well
actually if someone was saying what I
what I said in that comments and it sort
of goes to what Catherine was saying
actually earlier
is it was I was really concerned about
how people obviously set How firm set
prices looking forwards and how they
built an inflation expectations because
we do believe inflation is going to come
down obviously most strongly it's going
to come down and Catherine's already
mentioned the decision maker panel
survey where we ask firms what their
output prices are going to be looking
forwards and that's a good I think
that's a pretty good guide as to how
they're sort of thinking about the
future obviously and how they're
building an inflation expectations yeah
any and that that measure has has come
down it's come down you know by about a
you know two percent I think since sort
of last Autumn so uh you know we do
watch that carefully but that was my
point about it's how firms you know
incorporate uh both sort of backward
looking costs but also forward-looking
inflation expectations when they set
prices it wasn't meant to be directive
it was meant to be look we have a view
uh we think you know there is we think
inflation is going to come down if for
no other reason than the energy price
story
yeah how are you going to incorporate
that into prices
we can
a charts in the Box in the NPR on on the
inflation discussion one of the things
we can ask firms is do you set your
prices you know every half every six
months do you change your prices every
six months or do you change your prices
based on what you think cost structure
that's and and and pricing discipline is
going to be going forward that's called
State dependent pricing and so what we
what we observe is that when inflation
was Rising dramatically last year the
state dependent pricing going forward
was above the ones who only changed it
every six months
now what we observe is that firms that
are saying well I'm going to look at the
environment and how should I set my
prices the ones who set their prices
based on this state dependent pricing
where inflation is coming down in their
view it's going to be coming down in the
future they are pricing uh their
expected prices one year ahead are one
percentage Point lower than the ones who
change their prices every six months so
firms are incorporating the expectation
that inflation will be lower in the
future
well that's good to hear but it's going
quite slowly yes and so the Persistence
of high inflation to use the phrase that
people have used is is obviously going
to be stickier down than it is
it seems going up thank you
yeah very good point Siobhan I just want
to look at increasing interest rates in
the housing market
um and particularly uh for uh owner
occupiers compared to 2022 mortgage
possession claims have increased from
2889 to 4035
seven hundred thousand UK households
missed or defaulted on a rental mortgage
payment last month with the poster
borrowing going up again due to your
interest rates Rising mortgage holders
are under more pressure than ever when
you look at interest Rises do you think
or look at the impact they'll have on
repossessions and mortgage defaults
we do and also we particularly do if I
want to put my financial stability hat
on for a moment of course it is
important to us in terms of how it
affects the mortgage market and of
course the people involved now one thing
I would say and I think this is a very
good development in this country over
quite a lot of years now is that if you
go back I mean if you go back for
instance the early 90s
uh you know the the rates of household
repossession when interest rates went up
yes quite substantially was very high
there is now a lot of regulation in
place to uh sadly as you said in the
numbers it does happen but there's a lot
of Regulation to limit and to try to
avoid household repossession wherever
possible
um so I would expect the numbers to be
lower this time but but yeah but one
household being reassessed is not good
it's a bad outcome as you say
so we do look at it though if you don't
mind saying I mean I'll just broaden it
out the mortgage as I said earlier is
the question on the transmission
mechanism the mortgage marketers are
important
and the UK mortgage Market has changed
fundamentally since the since the last
interest rate rise cycle which is back
pre-financial crisis
um because back then it was
predominantly a floating rate market
today it's predominantly fixed rate
market so about 85 percent of marketers
are now fixed rates they're not as long
as in the US but they're still in the
sort of two five seven year range and
what we do look at a lot and it's been a
big Focus for the MPC in terms of the
work we do on the transmission of
interest rate Rises is how this is going
to come through
and what I can say I think we said this
in the reports and there's quite a good
chart actually I wish I showed at the
press conference which shows that
actually you know quite a lot of our
interest rate risers have not yet come
through in the mortgage Market I think
it's maybe two you know one-thirds come
through two-thirds hasn't and that's
because of the fixed rate resets that
are going to happen during the sort of
you know during the rest of this year
and going into next year we take that
into account when we consider the impact
of monetary policy
because it's important we do obviously
one way that the mortgage Market has
particularly changed is the intervention
of private renting and by to let
mortgages having huge impact on private
renters one in 20 tenants missed or
defaulted on a rent payment last month
the average rent in London is now over 2
000 pounds 11 higher than it was last
year two million householders missed or
defaulted on at least one mortgage rent
loan credit card or bill payment in
April
what has the impact of interest rates
been on the private rented sector and
what will be the impact in the future I
can tell you from my community's point
of view it's a huge increase in the
number of private tenants being evicted
I spent time last week with citizens
advice and Exeter and meeting people and
actually hearing just the same stories
and now I'm afraid I don't think much of
policy can be the answer to that problem
but I agree with you that this is
I'm afraid something that we have to
wash and you know be very alert to
because some of the stories I heard last
week were you know were very difficult
stories to be honest with you in terms
of the impact as you say on uh in the
rental market
and we would also we'd all agree that
scarcity in the housing market is a real
uh issue and we have a house building
crisis in the UK over the past 40 years
the overall social housing stock has
declined by 1.4 million homes in my
Borough in Merton we last year we had 72
two beds to let 34 three beds and two
four bedroom properties with 10 000
families on the waiting list and that
tells me I don't know about anybody else
we're simply not building enough homes
or doing enough to encourage new
developments with borrowing becoming
more expensive again
we are we are heading towards a further
house building crisis aren't we
well I I I I think your numbers are the
ones I hear quite often I have to be
honest the bank of England doesn't build
houses so I can't really go beyond that
um and uh the issue is about people
having to borrow more with house price
going up the average house price in the
UK is 10 times higher than it was in
1980 that means the size of a mortgage
that a household takes out has
drastically increased so even though
interest rates Rose uh to a higher 15 in
the early 90s rate Rises have a much
bigger impact today than they did in the
80s and 90s because households are
borrowing more is the era of cheap money
over and if so what does it mean for
people who have incredibly large rents
and mortgages if you don't want to say I
mean one thing and I go back I'll switch
to the financial stability side again at
the moment I mean one of the things
we've discussed about now in financial
stability hearings here is that the FPC
has in place a you know a policy which
actually limits the proportion of
mortgages that can be at high loan to
income ratios the FCA also has an
affordability tests in place those
policies are all designed to limit the
sense the amount of damage if you like
that is done in in the sort of situation
that we're in but I agree with you of
course that none of this can stop the
fact that these yeah
these cases do happen and I think it's
it's unfortunate and we obviously in a
broader policy approach we need ways to
ways to deal with that
what I would say on just just on
monetary policy is just come back to
this point about the switch in the
mortgage Market what it means is that
the transmission of interest rates
through the mortgage Market is actually
it you know it still it still has it's
still there but it takes longer to
happen because of the switch to from
floating to fixed rate
and
nursing Market over the last 12 months
rents in the UK have hit a record high
mortgages are costing families uh 1 400
pounds a month in London on average at
the same time we've got food and energy
Bills going up that we've already
discussed people feel that they're being
attacked from all angles and certainly I
see my advice surgery every week lots of
people just can't cope with mortgages
seemingly going up and up how much more
of this do you think people can
withstand because with regard to
Catherine's point about Consumer Power
if you have children you have to have
somewhere to live how much consumer
power do you have
well I think I can say something I've
said before but I think it's important
to say it frequently frankly which is
all inflation hurts and it hurts the
least well-off hardest this inflation is
particularly hard because it's
concentrated in energy food and as you
said housing costs
um and we yeah we we're very we're very
very aware of that
but if we don't get it back to Target
and don't get under control it gets
worse
and that's a hard message right now it's
a very hard message to give I don't like
giving up because you know I don't like
the fact that you know as you say there
are people who are experiencing real
suffering and it is people that you know
the least well-off who are you know
seeing the hardest effects but we have
to get this inflation back under control
next check
thank you very much indeed um
so um
so the some some optimism is breaking
into the gloomy Halls of the bank of
England uh of late which is encouraging
uh having been very pessimistic about
the uh prospects of the economy we're
now seeing uh some uh
definitely well predictions of of not
not negative growth and even Positive
Growth
um still at the pessimistic end of the
range of forecasts but but Sunshine is
breaking it which is which is
encouraging uh and last week there was
we spoke about it about the prospects
for supply side reform and the
importance of getting that right I just
wanted to know don't know who I'd want
maybe some of the independent members
what what you think are the
primary supply side reforms that we
should be hoping for and looking at in
order to boost growth in the UK
Catherine
I'm not going to comment done policies
that I don't control
I think it's very important to take the
estimates from obr and potentially from
other independent sources on prospects
for the supply side reforms to in fact
yield surprise side changes but I I take
those as given as opposed to and
incorporate them in my assessment and
judgment but I'm not going to make a
judgment as to which one is the best one
to do okay Professor generator you're
stepping down from the commission maybe
you can be more uh I mean the same
decision until the 5th of July okay so
yeah we take fiscal policy as a given
and then act on our tool to get
inflation back to Target but okay but I
suppose I'm just not not asking you
ready to comment on policy and certainly
not to make recommendations of policy
but in terms of the different aspects of
the supply side of the economy what are
you looking at that with with with
either hope or otherwise about what
might help to drive
growth what are the aspects of
the supply side that you think we should
be paying attention to again I'm not
going to comment on that we you know
take what government does in incorporate
it in our forecast uh
what is in the supply side if you want
to take a theoretical you know approach
um it's uh Capital so business
investment is very interesting it's
labor we've talked a lot about that
um and it's innovation
indeed those are the three elements that
are critical ingredients in prospects
for supply-side growth
and and I'll I'll give a plug for my
previous organization which is the oecd
they do a great job at looking at all
different elements that support supply
side growth and even will produce a
recipe that's best for the UK
and I would do that if I was still there
but I'm not okay thank you that's
helpful I think uh uh let me let me push
a little more on on the interaction
between those three elements of the
supply side then and looking
particularly at Labor and principally
immigration we're going to sounds like
we're going to get some big numbers
announced this week in terms of net
migration over the last year
do you recognize that high rates of
immigration can inhibit Investments
either in capital or indeed in skills of
the domestic Workforce and that that can
inhibit productivity growth in
particular well so we do not comment on
immigration
um just to be clear I mean our current
forecast takes the ons's population
projections as they are to count as we
understand it those projections are
going to be revised this week and we
will obviously incorporate it's another
point of doing conditional forecasts we
will take the new projections uh into
account but I don't think it's
appropriate for us to comment on
immigration okay
um
I tried
going back then to the to the to these
forecasts I'm appreciate there's been a
lot of conversations and I and I I share
the view uh answers left to think that
you know it is you are you've got to
make predictions in real time and you're
reacting to extremely volatile
circumstances
um I I Intrigue then what your sense
being honest about the effect of
pessimistic forecasts is on the on the
on do they become self self-fulfilling
how much do you actually have to
consider the effect of what you say in
terms of being objective
you're trying to be objective but
actually you know there's a dynamic
effect and consequence of your
predictions what would you say has been
the effect of the way that you've been
focused well it's interesting to say
that actually it's an interesting
question because during I mean if you go
back to November when we were
forecasting along was a deep recession
but a long recession
um since then actually if you look at
measures of consumer confidence actually
also business confidence they have
improved
um so on the face of it you would say
well it doesn't seem to have much effect
I think I'll take a step further in that
and say why is that well
what's happened during that period and
has been one of the contributors quite
sizable in terms as to why we've amended
our view on growth in the economy as the
Fallen Energy prices so you know I mean
back in November we were looking at sort
of you know a very high energy prices be
a winter when we weren't sure whether
Europe was going to have enough gas uh
to get through the winter and that
hasn't happened I mean this has been the
good news story of the last you know the
last six months really that we've come
through that period Energy prices are a
lot lower I mean they're over 50 lower
than they were looking forward than they
were back in November
um we obviously did get through the
winter we're going through now in the
period where Europe is much more stopped
with particularly with gas than it
actually has been in recent years so
yeah I think that's probably affecting
confidence more than sort of um our
forecasts really so it could it could be
a case but I don't think it has been in
this case Okay and then and then lastly
I'm just wanted to ask you about that
the the uh there's the good news on uh
what energy cost because when early in a
session earlier in the air I was big
even more pessimistic
and you I think um certainly in the AVR
on on the forecast for industry prices
but they do seem to perform how do you
account for this I mean if we just
suddenly discover some amazing new
source of LPG or what's that what's this
weather is it a number of things have
happened
um I mean first of all again you know
this was when some things do go right I
mean the the winter was actually not as
not as cold as it could be so of course
Europe this is because Europe's single
it is a single Market particularly for
gas
um I think secondly our staff produce
some quite nice charts for us which show
across Europe including this country
that's for a given level of temperature
gas consumption has been lower
thirdly a lot of work has already been
done on Supply so there is more
liquefied natural gas coming in from
other parts of the world uh to Europe
um now it's not it's I think the experts
which I don't include myself as one
would say it's not done and dusted yet I
mean certainly gas suppliers say to me
it will probably take to the end of 2025
at the current rate of building of
infrastructure to have Europe in a place
where it's sort of you know it's it's
broken the Russian dependence and can
rely on LNG from other parts of the
world but I think the position has
substantially changed already
okay maybe it was your pessimism that
helped to make people uh be more
abstemious with their energies perhaps
we've done perhaps they perhaps the
apocalypse actually
um
but in terms of the the forecast okay
thank you very much
I've done something similar they've been
good enough to agree to come in front of
our committee I believe today the IMF
have also said that we're going to avoid
a recession in the UK sadly
Unfortunately they don't submit
themselves to the same level of scrutiny
that you kindly do uh Emma thank you so
my question is going to focus around the
labor market so it says begin with
Governor are there some signs of an
easing in the labor market pressures
um
and also you
in your sort of report you expressed
some surprise at the extent of the labor
market tightness at the forecast so I
sort of wanted to begin with why why
this why the surprise was it not what
you were expecting and are you more
skeptical than perhaps you were about
the forecast at the labor market
situation will ease well the surprise
um was that quite a lot of countries in
the early phase of covert saw a
reduction in the size of the labor force
with people going into inactivity
remember inactivities people are not
working and not seeking to work I
suppose to unemployment when they're not
working but are seeking to work
and Britain Was Not Unusual in that
sense but what is unusual is that most
other countries saw that that that that
that change turned around in the sort of
as we went through covet and people
coming back into the labor force that
didn't happen
uh in this country now to your question
about what are we seeing now
um and we have some like Market numbers
out last week we are now seeing I think
I think in Aggregates about 60 percent
of that that change has reversed itself
now
um
but it is interestingly there were two
groups that of in the population that
showed greater inactivity originally one
was student age group and the other was
the 50 to 64 older somewhat older
I don't like saying this because I'm
going to the end
I'm teacher don't say anything
that's right
um now what we're seeing is that
actually this reversal is actually
mostly in the student group it's not so
much in the in the altar group so the
older group isn't coming back into labor
force now why is that
well ill health is is is is one reason
so long-term sickness is is I think
actually went up a bit last week again
as the reason for not coming back into
the labor force it's not it's not the
soul story I think I think there's you
know some people who probably chosen to
retire early I should say by the way
this has to be set against the
background of an aging population so
some of this increase in inactivity
would have happened irrespective of if
covet hadn't happened it will still have
happened what we're talking about is the
is the additional element beyond that
really
the force citing sickness as the
governor just said as the main course
has yet to show signs of reversing so I
wondered how much of this is impacted by
you know increased NHS waiting lists the
unmet need for medical treatment the
poor situation with the NHS at the
moment how much of that is making a
significant contribution to the
inflationary pressures that everybody's
feeling and feeling the pain of
so I mean I think in terms of Labor
Market developments I mean I think the
governor described what we see so in the
um there was a certain anomaly or at
least question in the data if you asked
people in the 50 to 64 age group as they
left the labor market to become inactive
why they were doing it it was a long
period uh through the end of kovid where
they were saying that was for early
retirement if you ask the people who
were
inactive the stock of people around the
flow of people transitioning into an
activity there was a rising share of
people referring to long-term sickness
what we have seen in the most recent
data as was said is is the former has a
little bit uh reversed now although most
of the increase in aggregate in terms of
the flow the reduced flow into
inactivity is coming from the younger
ages particularly the student population
and that percent or that view of
long-term sickness remaining an issue
and keeping people out of the market is
persisting I mean in the spirits of
trying to identify some good news I
think one thing we have seen in the most
recent data is that in that 50 to 64 age
group the percentage of people who say
they will have become an inactive and do
not expect to return to work has
declined uh
is there an assumption therefore that
some of these people if the sickness was
dealt with would be returning to the
labor market I mean that's possible I
mean we don't have
um like information a granular level to
know that but I mean I think
um I think the fact we've seen that
decline is consistent with the view that
there are people who previously were
saying uh these are separate questions
right so one question is why are you
inactive so they may report long-term
sickness there's another question which
asks given that you're an active are you
likely to return to work right so we
can't cross those two things but
nonetheless we do see
the new information
is citing long-term sickness that's the
reason for economic inactivity
that are looking to return to work if
that sickness is dealt with you don't
have any information
not in that form I see the attraction of
having that information we don't have
information quite in that form and I
wonder
um taking account of of the governor's
comments earlier but I wonder whether
the to what extent the upgrade to
economic growth in this forecast has
been driven by the higher than expected
migration and increased labor market
population
so as Andrew said we we take the ons
population projections
um so they are set to be revised and I
think there's General consensus of the
direction of revision the latest
revisions which we incorporated in our
forecast led to an increase in the level
of GDP of about two two tenths of a
percentage point over our forecast
Horizon so it's not a dramatic change I
think crucially the way we treat that in
the forecast is an improvement on the
supply side but it also Bears high
demand we have more people in the
economy so they're contributing to the
project the productive capacity of the
economy but also demand in the economy
so that sort of washes out in terms of
the pressure on resources and therefore
on inflation so it really is a more of a
growth story and that's the kind of
magnitude we've seen on the revisions to
the population projections we've seen
thus far thinking about the labor market
in general and of course I'm referring
to Legal migration people coming here
for uh and working
if that number was significantly reduced
to tens of thousands what impact would
that have on food prices on inflation if
you're looking to significantly reduce
the number of available people to work
well as I said I mean the way we treat
this in our forecasts and of course
those forecasts are subject to all the
um critiques that we discussed earlier
but the way we treat it as the basis for
discussion is migration of course we
don't have good information on illegal
forms of migration but I mean the way we
were treated I think in the same way is
uh is to say this increases when uh the
population projections rise that
increases the productive capacity of the
economy but it also means there's more
demand in the economy and so that's sort
of a wash in terms of the impact on
excess demand and its excess demand that
is the main driver of inflationary
pressures so the way we treat this if
you like by default as the basis for
discussion in our forecast as the
starting point for the debate uh that we
have discussed here that's the way I
would characterize the role the forecast
plays in the NPC discussions is in that
form and just to open it out to the
panel I mean what are all of your views
on whether the corner has been turned on
labor force participation are there
still concerns about the labor market
and how tight it is and what risks do
you see or possible if you're going to
be positive things to look forward to do
we see in the future labor market
so start with you governor
well I I think one of them you know when
I look at our forecasts and I look at
the way that we've revised them over the
last year I think one of the big one of
the biggest and most interesting
revisions for me is the profile of
unemployment
so yeah I think I think we've changed
our view quite substantially on what the
profile of unemployment is going to be
going forward it's consistent with
bringing inflation back to Target it's
now it's now a lot lower than it was
and that's born out of a lot of frankly
a experience in the data and be talking
to talking to firms around the country
about what their plans are uh yeah one
thing that
you know impresses me consistently when
I go around the country as firms say you
know they are going to retain labor they
are not going to they're not meant to
make people redundant because they find
it so hard to recruit people in the
current economy and you can see that the
vacancy to unemployment ratio which is
coming down but it's still high by
historical standards
um that they will adjust hours worked if
if they need to rather than actually
make people redundant so I mean it
certainly caused me to change my view on
what the profile of unemployment is
going to be now I think you can you can
very well put back to me I think it
would sort of go to Mr Baron's points
earlier on well what does that imply for
the you know for the path of inflation
downwards on the path of the economy is
is this something that is going to have
to cause us to adjust policy while we
watch it very carefully it's why we say
we're evidence driven
but I think certainly my view on the
sort of profile of the particularly of
unemployment has changed a lot in the
last year
it means that I think are useful to make
one uh you commented on skills we do
address that in again a theoretical
format with data in it so but there's a
way of thinking about how
the problem of matching skills means
that
employment can be higher and yet wages
can be higher too in other words if you
can't match the skills then you have to
look harder and you have to pay more and
but everybody is still employed so
that's that so-called beverage curve so
we do look at that and we do incorporate
that understanding in our assessment
it's it's uh it's so-called search and
matching model and it's uh a a a way of
evaluating the combination of who's at
work and how much they are paid because
it's not it's not always fits together
the same way over time so the search and
matching model is an import ingredient
in in our understanding about uh the
labor market I would agree and emphasize
that firms are in some sense scarred
from having to work so hard to hire
people over the last couple of years
that they are retaining their they are
retaining their labor force because most
of them are still looking most of them
still have open vacancies now if we want
to think about one bright bright
spot from the standpoint of inflation is
that we can we we have several different
surveys that look at
um the sort of the how much firms are
paying workers now and and are
negotiating uh for the for over the next
uh year or so
um that's the sort of the stock of
workers that's about six percent but
there's also workers who are changing
jobs or getting a new job and and in the
past over the past years those people
were getting 12
you know that changing job you get a 12
wage boost in this case we're looking at
a deceleration of these new job holders
new job takers uh where their wage
increases in the neighborhood of four
percent right so there is some
deceleration in that's that's a measure
of some loosening in the labor market
that we see in the most recent uh as I
say Changers to people who are changing
jobs thank you Professor I agree with
the last remarks by Catherine so we are
seeing
um we're starting off with a very tight
labor market but there are a clear signs
of loosening unemployment is edging up
um
vacancies are a vacancy over
unemployment is are falling and as
Catherine said for looking indicators of
pay growth have fallen significantly and
and they are yeah signaling or
indicating four percent
um again coming from from very high
peaks thank you and finally and
following on from the questions from my
college and what I'm really interested
in is we were talking about poverty and
the cost of living when you're looking
at making decisions about interest rate
Rises how much account you take of how
many more people are going to be pushed
into poverty by increased interest rate
Rises when you're making your decision
is that a factor in your decision if you
know that a half percent rise in
interest rate is going to push this many
people into well I think they're very
difficult
balance
you know in that area that we have to
strike is that we don't want to know we
don't want to do that
um
unfortunately if we don't get inflation
down it will it will have worse
consequences going forwards and that's
the that's the always the thing we have
to have in our mind now it does mean of
course that you know we we must use uh
you know the tool of interest rate Rises
carefully and you know sensibly
um and it does come to this question
about you know how quickly do you want
to bring inflation back to Target I mean
obviously we've got to bring it back to
Target we've got to bring it back to
talk incredibly people have got to think
yes we really believe they're going to
do it but we do have choices of course
as to just how fast we do it uh and I
would not Advocate we try to do it you
know by very severe increases in
interest rates because it's not just a
poverty question it would it would
actually
be contrary to our remit it would
actually cause instability
uh in the economy
um it would cause instability and
inflation it mostly could well cause an
undershoot of inflation thereafter
so we take that we take that very much
into consideration because it's
consistent with our remit you did you
want to come in
well I mean I I agree that I mean
clearly we are very concerned about
poverty and I agree very much that um
what we are doing in terms of setting
monetary policy to address the risks of
inflation is to bring inflation back to
Target in a way that doesn't induce
additional costs additional volatility
and the margin you're talking about is a
very important one that we have to take
into consideration when we do that
um you know I certainly think it's the
case that by establishing
re-establishing price stability in a
lasting way one of the main reasons
we're doing that is to provide some
protection from those vulnerable parts
of society which are most exposed to the
costs of inflation being high and as has
been said earlier on that's particularly
acute now given the forms of inflation
that we've seen coming through higher
energy prices higher food prices which
is proportionately a higher part of the
spending patterns of less but off in
society so it's that protection that
we're providing by containing inflation
reestablishing inflation at the two
percent Target on a lasting basis that
can create that confidence I also think
and this goes back to other things that
are being said earlier that creates the
environment in which you know households
across the income distribution and firms
of various types can take their
investment decisions and other longer
term decisions which allow them you know
to get the education to invest in
factories and create the Innovation
dynamism and productivity that
ultimately living standards in this
country rely on it is taken directly
into account then when you're making a
deliberations the number of people
it's embodied into the remit we have as
to how we bring how we perceive to bring
inflation back to Target
thank you Jeff
and I think you caught my Andrea also
and uh John hi thanks Joe can I just uh
in looking forward
um explore the possibility that you may
now be over tightening with regard to
your interest rate Rises which itself
can as you've just said can cause a lot
of pain you know I
I agree you should never shoot the
messenger but at the end of the day one
of your key roommates is to keep
inflation at around two percent if not
below and you don't have to rely on City
forecast to base your decisions on that
uh remit I mean I pointed a possible
point to a possible contradiction in the
Bank of England's policy I mean on the
one hand
um you know interest rate Rises as we've
said take perhaps six to nine months to
have a because of their lag effect their
effect on the economy if not longer
now up to certainly May the 11th when
you increase your inflation forecast
from 3.9 to 5.4 I think
he was still raising interest rates
despite that knowing that that lag
effect was going to be there now if you
believed in your inflation forecasts
why are you still raising interest rates
well because as we said I mean we're
evidence-based and they're conditional
forecasts and the world moves on the
conditions move on
so we have seen as we've been as we've
discussed you know during this morning
we have seen I would say more evidence
of two things we've seen more evidence
of
what I hope is sure to run inflation
pressures but pressures which
nevertheless are evidence I mean we had
a discussion about food crisis earlier
one of the things that we've embodied
into the forecast is that the unwind of
food price inflation is going to take
longer than we thought it would have and
then we have to consider what the
effects of that are the second one is
persistence more generally
um now interestingly so actually the
evidence
particularly in areas like you know
wages and service prices which have a
big labor content they haven't really
say gone that far off course to the one
we had in February but as we've
discussed earlier we are very worried
about the risk that's why we've got it
in the risk more than the central the
central forecast that this sort of
asymmetry of unwind of inflation will
take place
uh and that is for me certainly if I go
back to the decision we took in May and
the vote in the vote how I voted in that
you know that was a you know substantial
consideration at this point can I put it
in another way very briefly I mean
you've made big upward revisions to your
grades for forecasts and in fact your
inflation forecast on the 11th of May
that was a big jump yes and yeah you
know by Bank of England standards yeah
yeah the last increase came in at I
think 0.25 there's been a modest
moderation I mean does that suggest
we're nearing the peak in interest rates
well
well I think we made a switch really in
February from uh language that we used
when we described the reasons for taking
the decisions which had a clear steer
that we thought there was more to come
to not doing that but saying we would be
evidence-based we would reach our
decisions
we always reach our decisions on the
base of the evidence but there wasn't an
underlying if you like prior
uh starting assumption that was
deliberate in my mind uh because I think
although I can't tell you whether we're
near to the peak I can't tell you we're
at the peak I think we are nearer to the
peak than we were and certainly in my
mind we were approaching a point when it
was sensible to to make that switch
from being more directional to being
saying no we're just briefly and very
finely may I just swing to Silvana you
actually in the interest rate decisions
argued or certainly encouraged therefore
there to be no increases Beyond I think
it was three percent
so can I just ask you then given that
you've voted for no change in the bank
range since it was three percent is
monetary policy now in your view
um alarmingly tight
well you know
you know how best to meet the two
percent Target in the medium term
and the role of monetary policies once
those shocks occur you know how best to
carry out this
um or move inflation to them to do its
targets
um
the NPC has raised rates very fast and
we know that there are important lacks
in the transmission of policies so in
the staff's estimates about
one-fifth of the transmission has
already happened and the rest is about
to happen so you think they are too
tight so my assessment is that you know
conditional on this path for markets
rates we will undershoot the Target and
that would be my judgment and this is
why I have involved in for no races and
again the logic of the forecast and any
forecast at this point is that the
enormous shocks that we face and pushed
up on inflation over the past 18 months
and meteoric increase in in the prices
of energy and other Commodities and the
after effects of the Pandemic those are
going into reverse and they will pull in
down on inflation over the next 18
months there are second round effects
and this is a concern how to balance
those risks
and you know my judgment is that we're
on more than on track and
I don't think definitely
um
thanks yep just about the child care
policy obviously it's quite a big impact
potentially on availability of Labor in
the workforce and I just wonder to what
extent that has an impact on your
forecasting for a couple of years down
the line in the context of whether in
fact we're tightening too fast now uh
perhaps Hue first and then Dr Mann thank
you yeah so we um I mean in a bit in the
spirit of commentary earlier when we
don't comment on specifically on fiscal
policy but in terms of how that has been
incorporated as an announced fiscal
policy into the Baseline forecast and in
our forecasting framework so this is in
the spirit of what we discussed earlier
we have a forecast which is the basis
for discussion the labor market measures
in general have been included in the
same manner that our colleagues at the
obr have included them in their forecast
so we are relying on their expertise and
focus there and so that what that does
in the obr forecast is raise labor
market participation by about 0.3
percentage points or just over a hundred
thousand people uh by 27-28
um within our own uh forecast which has
a shorter Horizon because we're looking
more at cyclical developments and the
obr is looking more at trend-like
developments around the sustainability
of public finances
there is a more modest impact of around
two tenths of a percentage point on the
level of activity and that partly
reflects the fact that the rollout is
not immediate but takes place through
time and I just would reiterate the
point I made earlier when we discussed
the population projections
um I mean there is a combination of
demand and Supply effects here so the
feed through into inflationary impact is
not one-to-one in terms of that but
there will also be greater employment
and so forth that will have demand
effects so the impact on excess demand
will uh will be less than the impact on
the overall level of activity thank you
Dr Mann
um I think Hugh has set out very well
the way we incorporate possible
evolution in in employment and and both
on Supply and the demands and from the
child care policy but I do think it's
important I would like to respond to uh
the comment about is monetary policy too
tight
um at you know my speech in February I
set out a two-step framework for the
transmission of monetary policy to
inflation and real activity and I
cautioned at that time that the change
in bank rate was an insufficient metric
as the change in the bank rate uh
affects many other asset markets and
prices
um and I offered a new Financial
conditions index which Incorporated uh
bank rate changes as well as the
endogeneity of these other asset prices
the bottom line on that is tightening
and tight
are not the same
there has indeed been tightening
in financial conditions associated with
our change in bank rate
but
by my judgment
Financial conditions are not tight
and in particular real rates
are still below zero
so
from that standpoint
we can't make judgments about Peak and
path
of the bank bank rate because it's data
dependent I agree with that entirely
we've talked a lot about what kind of
data we look at and I look at in
particular on inflation and inflation
expectations and those are what I will
be looking at for the next round
very interesting thank you thanks thank
you I think everyone's had their their
chance at least once and uh I'm going to
now wrap things up if I may John uh in
terms of uh the evidence that we've
heard uh today uh none of us even know
what tomorrow's inflation number is
going to look like we all hope that it
will finally show that we are on the
path that you have been forecasting uh
we accept that all these decisions are
made in real time what we try to do in
these sessions is tease out the things
where we think that perhaps more of the
contemporaneous evidence
could have been taken into account we're
not trying to argue in favor of
hindsight we're arguing in favor of the
facts at the time I think what today's
session has also pointed out is just how
challenging the act of foresight is and
some of the challenges that you've had
with your modeling I'm not entirely in
agreement with my colleague Dame Angelo
Eagle who said that we shouldn't shoot
the messenger because we see your role
as so much more important in our economy
than just being the messenger of the
forecast you are the actor whose
institution has been given the
responsibility of meeting the inflation
Target and this is a key part of the
Parliamentary scrutiny in that regard
and so your accountability to Parliament
means that we get to ask these these
these questions on behalf of the British
public and thank you very much for your
time in particular thanks Professor tin
rail for your time on the committee and
your evidence today but at this point
I'm going to declare today's session
over order order thank you